[Music]
let's begin the news out in Ukraine
where the Russians and Ukrainian forces
are fighting each other to recapture
lost territory Russia's Relentless
shelling has hit the cities of mikolayev
and bakmut leaving a trail of
Destruction and Ukrainian cities they're
plunged Into Darkness after Moscow
struck energy infrastructure and power
facilities reducing electricity supplies
to nearly a third
we're live in Ukraine's Capital Kiev but
first let's head over to chromatosk in
the Donetsk region assadbag is joining
us live from there it looks pretty
horrendous behind you Assad bring us
first of all up to speed with what it
looks like
well this was hit in the early hours of
yesterday morning and it's not far from
where we're staying in fact we heard the
air raid sirens go off we heard the loud
thuds and then we felt the shock waves
where we were staying the walls actually
shook all that team was uh woken up then
we came here in the morning and the fire
was still raging now uh if I could just
show you that this seems to be a factory
a warehouse it was hit by three missiles
just around the corner from here is a
massive crater that one of those
missiles has left no one was injured but
we were just being told by the owner
that the damage goes up to about 10
million dollars now we're not sure
exactly what the Russians were targeting
here but what we can tell you is when we
got here yesterday morning the fire was
still ongoing and the fire service was
here trying to distinguish that we saw
about three fire engines trying to bring
that under control but this is what's
happening we're about 50 kilometers from
uh one of the front lines but Russia is
still able to strike targets deep within
Ukraine with their missiles and Rockets
and it's also been a rough night I think
in bakmut what do we know about what is
happening there asset are the Russians
making gains
well it depends who you listen to so the
Russians are claiming that they're
making gains the ukrainians are saying
that they've repelled attacks on Bahamut
from several angles on that City but
what I can tell you is that we were
there yesterday and we had to leave
because the Rockets were going over our
heads and we were forced to leave that
City now I was also there back in May
and the situation since May has
definitely changed there's more
destruction in the city there's fewer
people many people have left and where
we had gone to in the city before back
in may we can no longer reach that area
because the Russians are way closer now
the battle does change sometimes the
ukrainians say that they've pushed the
Russians further out the Russians
claiming that they're getting closer and
closer to that City but what I can tell
you is that yesterday that there was a
lot of firing going on lots of shells
being fired Rockets been fired lots of
Destruction fewer people there but right
now that City remains in the hands of
the ukrainians but the Russians are
making a push for it they're putting
considerable effort into taking
just not far away from what they're also
trying to take that strategic location
because if they manage to take those two
places it gives them a bit of a
strategic Advantage here in the East but
so far the ukrainians are saying that
they're holding on to it but definitely
I would say that the Russians are way
closer to Bahamut than they were back in
May all right thanks so much assadbag
well let's talk to Al jazeera's Muhammad
jamjun he's live in the Ukrainian
Capital where there have been large
power Cuts so what does life feel like
there on this Friday with all the power
cuts
well Sammy it's a very interesting
atmosphere here in Kiev let me first
walk you through what's happened over
the course of the past 24 hours or so um
the morning of the 27th yesterday you
had Russian missile strikes targeting
um Power facilities in the key region in
the center of the country and because of
that you have many electric companies
here in the country and many officials
who have said that power will be reduced
in the central part of the country and
in the key region by at least 30 percent
that's what the deficit is at this hour
now that includes not just the region of
Kiev and the City of Kiev where we are
the capital of the country it also
includes regions like chernohev and
Stormer because of that there have been
a lot of power blackouts in those areas
now specifically here in the city of
Kiev interesting today
Friday you're seeing life pretty much as
normal people coming out children in
playgrounds people going about their
daily business last night we were out on
the streets many neighborhoods in the
capital were much darker than they
usually are there have been power
outages over the course of the past
couple of weeks there have been
schedules implemented by the National
Power Company so that you have
neighborhoods here in the capital that
go at least four hours without power
they're disconnected from the grid you
also have other business owners shop
owners restaurant owners that are
voluntarily turning the lights off
outside of their shops and their
restaurants to try to conserve on energy
because there has been a concerted
message that's being put out there by
officials for people to try to do
whatever they can to limit their power
consumption right now so they do not tax
the grid as much as it has been taxed
now last night a lot of neighborhoods in
darkness we were out there street lights
that were out even traffic lights that
were out and yet people were coming out
they were bringing their families out
they were going to restaurants sitting
in the Darkness is when Candlelight
having their food really showing the
resilience that you see throughout
Ukraine during this war to that end
Ukrainian president velodi mirzolinski
came out in the dark in the city last
night delivered a video message to the
citizens of this country to speak about
the spirit of Ukraine even in the midst
of these attacks against the power grid
here's more of what he had to say
will not break us to hear the enemy's
anthem on our land is scarier than the
enemy's rockets in our Sky we are not
afraid of Darkness the darkest times for
us are not the times without light but
those without will our military is
strong volunteers are tireless partners
are reliable and people are unbreakable
the second Army of the world will get
smaller and smaller there will be more
and more losses for the Army I'm sure
that hostile propaganda does not work
provocations do not work threats do not
scare any tough winter will not scare us
we know that the darkest night becomes
the dawn
Sammy the fact that you are having power
outages at this level in the capital of
the country clearly shows what a toll
those Russian strikes against the power
infrastructure are having on Ukraine and
yet you do encounter this resilience
from the citizens here people who say
they will try to continue with their
daily lives with their normal lives as
much as possible Sammy all right
Muhammad thanks for uh covering that for
us